on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight up here is Morgan uncensored in
her most
her most yet Meghan Markle openly
accuses the royal family of leaking and
conspiring against it to protect other
members of The Firm and much more of
this are they are we gonna have to
endure
after months of anti-Semitic Rants and
his removal from twitters you can invest
pioneering art now be censored by
streaming platforms I talked to one
prominent Jewish journalist who thinks
yay's music should play on
and another TV exclusive internet
sensation liver King speaks to me live
after the fitness influencer without it
as a steroid user lying to his millions
of fans that it was all oh natural
[Music]
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored
good evening from mother welcome to
Facebook and sends to the British stiff
upper lip used to be celebrated it meant
being proud of our fortitude in the face
of adversity times may be tough but we
keep pounding soldiering on plugging
away muddling through we keep calm and
carry on that was the British way but
the stoic stiff upper lips disappeared
doesn't it beneath a curled lower lip of
victimhood it's now fashionable to be
fragile it's trendy to be traumatized
it's Valiant to be a victim as Dame
Joanna Lumley told Prospect magazine
this week Sticks and Stones can break
your bones but so can silence because
it's violence trauma used to be
something you suffered in a car accident
or severe distress caused by a
life-changing tragedy now everything is
traumatic and everybody is traumatized
criticism is now shaming disagreements
become hate and any level of reasonable
skepticism about massive social change
is apparently a phobia a lot of reasons
why this victim culture spread like a
virus but it has a lot to do with role
models and there's no bigger
self-declared victim no more famous
princess of self-pity than Meghan Markle
well apart from her husband Harry
Netflix today released another trailer
for the final three hours is it the
final three hours I doubt it of the
Harry and Megan show it's all out
tomorrow the battle lines have now very
clearly been drawn our monarchy is the
Menace Megan and Harry it's poor
unsuspecting oppressed victims
that was a real kind of war against
Megan and
I've certainly seen evidence that there
was negative briefing from the palace
against Harry and Megan to
suit other people's agendas
Meg became this scapegoat for the palace
and so they would feed stories on her
whether they were true or not
to avoid other less favorable Stories
being printed
you would just see it play out like a
story about someone in the family would
pop up for a minute and they go I've got
to make that go away
but there's real estate on a website
homepage There's real estate there on a
newspaper front cover and something has
to be filled in there about someone
Royal
this barrage of negative articles about
the breakdown of the relationship with
her father was the final straw in a
campaign of negative nasty coverage
about her
a real war against Meghan Markle give me
a break a real war is what's happening
now in Ukraine where people are actually
being killed murdered by barbaric
Invaders from Russia where babies are
being blown to pieces
it's not because somebody at Buckingham
Palace may or may not have told a
newspaper that you're a piece of work
which by the way fact check you are
I can tell you from all my time editing
newspapers that's not how this works
it's not true that the royal family
constantly brief against other members
of their families to newspapers that's
not how this
actually happens in the real world only
in Megan and Harry's self-serving
constantly negative world view of all
this it's now clear that the final
episodes of his constructive reality
show will actually construct a reality
that's recognizable only to them they'll
directly attack the royal family they're
still profiting from a vast vast profit
by the way to tell a sob story in which
they are the world's ultimate victims
they're milking this clickbait culture a
social media validation which rewards
whining without evidence and wallowing
without reason they're all families
should do the exact opposite of
everything these professional victims
that's what they are now represent
they should do what they've always done
Keep calm carry on ignore them and just
rise effortlessly effortlessly above
this nonsense because without the
imaginary War without their Royal status
they're nothing are they there's a
couple of see-list celebrities living in
a mansion in California there's a lot of
those you've got a house out there
myself
nobody better represented the British
stiff upper lip than the late Queen
Elizabeth herself of course and it might
not be fashionable but over the next few
days the British Monarchy
should just follow her lead
well joining me now is the former Royal
correspondent Michael Coles Sunday Times
Royal editor Roy Nick and former
conservative MP and Whitaker uh I don't
know where to start really Roy let me
start with you because you had a great
piece in the Sunday Times at the weekend
where you went through forensically a
lot of the claims in the first three
episodes and a lot of the stuff that
just didn't ring true to me you nailed
not least for me one of the most
egregious parts of it which was her
attempt to say look there's this nice in
my family that I really like so it's not
true I don't like them all and the only
reason she wasn't at the wedding with my
mother was because someone at the palace
told me it wouldn't be a good idea but
what was the truth
that was not the account that two people
who worked very closely with Megan and
Harry told me both of whom had very
specific Recollections of that
conversation with Megan which was Megan
saying by the way I've got a nice that
was news to the Palace I'd never heard
of Ashley Hale before and I'm close to
her but I don't want to invite her
because it will expose her to far too
much media scrutiny to which the aide
said fine no problem it was Megan
telling the palace what was going to
happen not the palace giving any stare
or any guidance as to which family
members would come they said they wanted
more family to come because it would
look less weird of course it was so
weird as it was one member of the family
from either side of her family and then
you have all these celebrities she's
just met I mean it was just a weird
thing to observe anyway at that wedding
but to then find out that this niece
would have been the other 50 that was
invited and to concoct a kind of
narrative look you see how nice I am to
my family
but I wasn't allowed to bring them to
the well it totalized
lies phrase used by one of the former uh
members of the household that I spoke to
um for several of the claims that were
made in the first three episodes what
else struck you as from your contacts as
being disingenuous at best
um you see the other thing I was quite
pleased to learn was that you might have
read when you did very kindly the 30
point the 30 chapter dossier on how to
prepare for Royal life well this is
really significant because she made a
big play in the in the documentary of
saying nobody prepares you to be a
princess there's no one giving you any
advice you're basically as she put it
generally thrown to the walls right what
is the reality and what happened with
her so the reality is that months before
actually even months before they got
married six months before
um she had I mean she had assistant
private secretary's working with her she
had the whole Communications team
working with her but on top of that
Harry's then private secretary Adeline
Fox
spent weeks preparing this vast dossier
30 chapter dossier of everything you
might need to know about preparing for
public life Royal life the Constitution
ladies and waiting charity work arts in
the UK and with every chapter it was
just full of information it had 30
specific experts on each chat and each
chapter saying we'll set up a meeting
for you Megan um which took up to so
that was a blatant lie again but also
what about the obvious elephant in the
room she's marrying Prince Harry who has
observed Royal ritual At Close Quarters
for his entire life she couldn't just
have turned to him and said how do I
curtsy to your grandmother well there
was a very big segment in that part of
the the episode obviously the mark
curtsy but also saying I didn't know how
to do walkabouts I'd never heard where
I'd never seen one I mean she was
marrying someone who'd done hundreds but
regardless of that I was told that there
was a lot of prep
I just think it's so disingenuous I
think he's lying Michael where are we
with this because the royal family are
in a really difficult Place aren't they
because their normal stance on these
things is to say nothing I firmly
believe they shouldn't get involved in
this because I think if you lie down
with dogs you get fleas and these two
are behaving like rabid dogs at the
moment
um but is the remote if you're Prince
William for example and this is your
brother branding you all a bunch of
colors racists I mean if that was one of
my brothers there would be a Tipping
Point as it would be the other way
around you say where are we I'll tell
you where we are we're at a new low with
this self-obsessed couple I've had to
look at that trailer three times it's 71
seconds of Venom and vitriol and what it
reveals is princely paranoia it starts
off with him saying I'm on a freedom
flight as if he's talking about the last
helicopter out of Saigon in 1975. he's
actually on a private flight to a
mansion in British Columbia which is one
of the most beautiful places in the
world but you ask a very good question
because
now it all depends what's in this next
three episodes if there are issues of
veracity I.E lies are told in plain
English then I think it is beholden upon
Prince William to answer it line by line
rebuttal
and refutation because I'm afraid it
won't do the normal row of poses put
your head in the sound like an ostrich
never explain never complain the queen
never did no the queen mother never did
but this is and I know I know that the
position of our new king and queen
they're very much of the never complain
never explained because actually every
time any of the rules I've ever tried to
explain anything it normally rebounds
horrifically badly but Diana's Panorama
interview Andrew's news night interview
even Charles's interview none of it ever
really works in the way they think but
that single line some Recollections may
vary yeah that went home with people in
other words other people remember it
completely differently but this is very
serious because the charge of racism is
toxic it's toxic and it's very easy to
make but it's almost impossible it's a
refute yes it's impossible to prove a
negative and that's what's so playing
the race card is cowardly because it
deprives the person accused of the no I
totally agree I totally agree and we saw
around William's anger when he took that
moment yeah so he said this is very much
family you're bringing down with him I
can't even imagine you sitting through
hours of this even minutes maybe of this
have you watched any of the Netflix
documentary
here's I haven't seen so much as the
second of it uh and uh today with my
column and the express I didn't refer to
this precious couple at all because I
actually think that the way to deal with
them is to ignore them just to
completely ignore them they are thriving
on the publicity but it's publicity
which has an end because they cannot go
on inventing ever more things forever
more about the royal family this has a
natural shelf life and uh I think you
know what we should do is just let them
say it all ignore them give them no
publicity and just let them get on with
it I mean I think your introduction was
excellent in which you talked about the
cult of victimhood because in a wider
sense uh Joanna Lumley was talking about
women and how women now think that
there's something clever about being
victims whereas you know she and I had
to fight very hard to get quality and we
got it and we won and ever since then
people have been looking around saying
what's the next grievance yeah I think
that's a very good point Roya where does
this all go I mean where does it end is
there an Enderman if your currency is
trashing your family and you're making
literally hundreds of millions of
dollars from doing it and the Netflix
the first three episodes did very well
apparently for Netflix so they're happy
so they'll be chucking more money at
them I don't think anybody wants to hear
their other stuff what they want to hear
is Royal bashing
um but how long is that sustainable well
let's see what happens on January the
10th when the boy brings out his book I
think you know I would imagine you know
he will be keeping a fair bit back for
that where does it end I think
ultimately Harry and Megan probably feel
they've got a little bit more Royal
currency to play out in the states and
you know better than anyone that lasts
for only a certain amount of time
I think it will carry on with the royal
family here keeping calm and carrying on
for a long time how damaging has it all
been there it's been damaging there's no
doubt about it you know I think in the
Commonwealth and in America the racism
stuff is really beginning to stick
um do you know what I was out in Boston
a couple of weeks ago with the wells's
and there was a lot of love for William
and Kate there um the races and stuff
wasn't sticking as much as I thought it
would but
people in America have a very different
view to here and Boston's a tough town
it's an Irish town and they were they
were cheering them and you know uh what
is extraordinary to me is uh Prince
Harry served this country gallantly he
was a forward artillery Observer he sat
in the front seat of an Apache
helicopter shooting up the Taliban he
could have come home in a body bag that
must have been pretty scary from time to
time what is it within the palace that
so got him frightened it really is
extraordinary no I think it's as simple
as he's not the brightest of bulbs in
the Tulip patch and I think he's been
lassoed by a very cynical manipulative
woman who has basically taken him over
people don't like me saying things like
that because I think he's sexist but I
think that's honestly what's happened
she's a lot she's a lot older than him
she's been married before and divorced
and I think she's come over here seen
the main seen the main gig and taken him
and it's her it's now her license to
become what she wanted to be which is a
huge star but they've sold out body and
soul to Netflix they're on their little
if she doesn't catch she won't care
about any of this she's got what she
wants she was a b-list actress in a show
I got I enjoy that yes it was good but
he wasn't that popular it was just a
good show
um but she's got what she wants she's
now top of the tree getting Awards
earning gazillions and a big star right
he is in my view looking like the Trump
and the picture because he's the one now
who's betrayed his country his family
and everything else and Whitaker you're
you're demonstrating with your head some
kind of visceral reaction I'm just not
sure what it is
yes well I mean to the question as to
what happened to Harry you know after he
came back from Afghanistan and why is it
all so different it's very
straightforwardly Meghan Markle he is
Bewitched he's utterly and completely
Bewitched and if he had any sense at all
he would have started to see by now uh
the way the land lies but he doesn't
because he has utterly besotted by her
and he's being taken along with her he
would never have done any of this stuff
on his own that's for a certainty no I
don't I honestly don't think he would
have done and I think or if he tried I
think he would have been talked out of
it I just think at the moment he's
trapped in what will become a world of
pain nobody can leave their family
on mass just leave all of them and leave
their country and lose all their
reputation particularly when they served
their country so valiantly as he did he
was a very good soldier and deserves
great credit for that but nobody can
give all this up and be happy and it's
interesting they went for freedom and
happiness the one thing they don't look
is remotely happy I mean she does she's
the cat that got the cream he looks
increasingly angry and miserable and
resentful so it hasn't worked he hasn't
looked free and happy he looks trapped
and miserable
that's my take
um anyway look great to see the pat um
sadly we will be talking about this
again probably tomorrow night because
another three episodes I'll be up at 8
A.M to try and get through it last time
it was about the 60 60 Minute moment
that I began to feel I just began to
feel something coming through my torso
my blood began to curdle and I began to
feel I'm literally never getting this
time back in my life
as I watched yet another at this point
we were the biggest victims in the
entire universe I mean it was like awful
to be in my Palace treat it so badly
terrible oh yeah it was it was awful it
was terrible my dad stopped giving me
Millions
really your little wapless off wait why
don't you do a job a proper job anyway
as you can see I'm working myself up for
the next three episodes and we'll give a
fair and impartial and balanced take on
what will be a gruesome three hours tune
in tomorrow night to my Piers Morgan
uncensored special edition on the
rolling nightmare that is Megan and
Harry the documentary
it's the nauseating self-serving
snoozefest the whole world is Raging
about I I'm gobsmacked it's just
ridiculous you destroyed yourselves in
this country with your ludicrous
hypocritical Behavior
that I wasn't being thrown to the Wolves
I was being fed to the Wolves they were
never willing to tell the truth to
protect us Meg became this scapegoat for
the palace this was a fight Worth
Fighting For
oh shut up
well still to come
we'll have more after the break
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to Facebook
my exclusive interview with internet
sensation liver king after one of the
most famous influencers out there was
outed as a steroid user lying to his
millions of fans and his body was all
natural talk to him live the first a
union representing Coast Guards and the
water forces called on the Home
Secretary to resign in disgrace from a
death of four migrants in the channel
Unity Brotherman of vilifying and
demonizing the Very people she's now
feigning sympathy with this have a look
I would love to be having a front page
of the Telegraph and the flight a plane
taking off to Rwanda that's my dream the
mob needs to be stopped the British
people deserve to know which party is
serious about stopping The Invasion on
our
[Music]
house I know that everyone in this house
and across the country will join me in
expressing our profound sadness and
deeper sympathies for everyone affected
by this terrible event
well joining me now is associate editor
of the Daily Mirror Kevin McGuire and
talk to you if you contributor Esther
Krakow and times columnistic
conservative peer Daniel engelstein well
welcome to all of you um
and sorry I'm also joined by talking
about let me start with Kate Kate thanks
for joining me um you're down there in
the corridors of power just actually
you're not the only one there at the
moment
um but you're shining out like a shaft
of gold as all around is lazy and gone
gone home so thank you um
two things he strikes me are gripping
this government right now one is this
whole issue of how to deal with the
migrants and this awful thing today this
story today of the deaths and the
channel will just raise that Specter
again is what are we going to do about
this and what is the Humane way to deal
with this problem and the second thing
of course is the fact that almost
everybody's on strike and what they do
about that what is the mood down there
sort of collectively about all this with
this government because it feels like
from here they're really on the ropes
and they don't seem to be having a lot
of answers
yeah I think within the party certainly
the back benches on both of those issues
there is some tension there is some
concern that perhaps the Prime Minister
hasn't necessarily yet fully got to
grips with either immigration
particularly illegal Boat Crossings
those small Boat Crossings and the issue
of Strikers but here's what I think the
problem here is is that so often with
both of these policies the government
talks about the policy in a broad way it
doesn't necessarily talk about the human
impact and that's where things come
unstuck when you think about those small
Boat Crossings you had Zoella Bravo and
there what she's doing is she's talking
tough because she knows her backbenches
and often conservative voters believe
that the party should really have a grip
on the number of people entering the
country which the reality is and she's
admitted the home office currently
doesn't now we've seen a raft of policy
introduced over the last couple of days
which is designed to deal with it but
critics always say it ignores the human
element and that's brought up so starkly
when you see things like the four people
who've died trying to cross the channel
in the middle of the night reports that
there are women and children on that
boat even now obviously unconfirmed at
this stage but in a desperate desperate
attempt to get to the UK which again
highlights this need for safe and legal
routes which the government says that it
will tackle the same could be said for
strikes you know when the government
talks about striking workers it talks
about pay it talks about inflation but
actually the reality is that for lots of
people around the country they are
struggling to pay the bills particularly
when it comes to nurses and that's why
you see so many people sympathetic to
them walking out on strike yes there
will be problems there'll be those who
say they shouldn't do it but there are
many many around the country who say
well actually the reality is they can't
afford not to and I think that human
element is where the government
sometimes can come unstuck on both of
these policies and others yeah I think
that's absolutely right and I think
they're failing to connect with people
and people are feeling angry they're
feeling fearful they're feeling
impoverished and they're feeling there's
no leadership and I I full sympathy with
Richie sunac he's just coming to pick up
this mess in fact congratulations to
because today he passed Liz truss's
Milestone of being the shortest serving
prime minister ever so he's more popular
than Liz truss and the lettuce which has
got to be two things to cheer him up but
this is like being handed the biggest
Hospital pass in modern political
history isn't it the polls are
catastrophic for the conservatives and
people are crying out for answers from a
government which right now doesn't
really seem to have any
yeah and the reality is the answers to
those problems even if you just take
immigration and health but there are
many many others will take years they
they really will these are deep embedded
problems nobody could turn this around
quickly even if you had all the money in
the will in the world you wouldn't be
able to they are difficult and they're
entrenched and the reality is that Rishi
sunak he realizes that that's why he's
basically made himself personally
responsible for cutting at least some of
the backlog in those Asylum claims by
the end of 2023 now whether we can do it
or not is another thing entirely all
he's focusing on is trying to meet some
of those targets by the time the next
election comes around but I think the
reality for most people around the
country and for lots of MPS here on the
conservative back benches is that they
can see that there's just no way that
they can sell the fact that the Tory
government has solved these issues by
the time that vote comes around and that
people in the country already know it
and and that's a problem yeah and I
think we're heading for for a tough
recession in the next year and that's
going to make things 10 times worse okay
we can thank you very much indeed for
joining me I appreciate it Danny
is there anything the conservatives can
do in time to turn around what appears
to be the Titanic heading to electoral
Devastation Iceberg I doubt it but I I
think that that's not the right question
actually for the government to ask
itself I think what it has to do is to
try to govern in the interest of the
country try to I mean I was pleased
yesterday that Rishi sunak did seem to
set out some solid workable steps that
were the result of diligent systematic
thinking rather than just loose rhetoric
there's no point talking about the
problem I think it's very unlikely that
that it will resolve the position for
the conservatives electorally but the
right thing for the government to do is
the right thing and I don't what is it
what is the right thing on the migrant
crisis to start with what is the right
thing to do okay it is it is definitely
lies in bilateral deals or the kind that
the government did with Albania of the
kind that they are trying to do with
France it is definitely about trying to
ensure that when people come there are
places for them to go that are not very
expensive hotels making the problem of
expense you know part of the sort of
panic of it
um and it'll it'll have to also grapple
with the problem of legal difficulties
of whether these people can stay here
because for them at the moment we seem
to have a rate of acceptance of Asylum
that's much higher than elsewhere we
need to look about why that is the case
as well right as well and also came in
you can't get away with that if a third
of the people who've come in this year
are from Albania and they're mainly
working age men that clearly is not what
this has all been sold by some on the
left in particular which is these are
all helpless refugees or War zones
they're not now in the case from a
perfectly good country but they just
want to come and have a better life here
no and I accept I think Albania is a
safe country yeah most of those men come
over they work and then they send the
money back and then they return
themselves but I thought Kate McCann
summed it up wonderfully was very
measured yeah in that I think it feels
that the government's lost uh hearts in
mind it's out of touch problems are
running away from it now on the economy
and so on inflation you could see well
who could have predicted covert and then
Putin's Invasion which sent World fuel
prices sorry no you can't you can't get
all the blame for that brexit was a
self-inflicted national uh wound but the
question of migration and having a
system that works been in power for 12
years
now and and to be fair I don't think
labor ever got their heads around it
either they did eventually but you can't
people are always going to try and come
to Britain look it's a compliment people
want to come the labor except now that
Blair you know Blair in his tenure he
tried to open things up say to Eastern
Europe and he now recognizes that that
was probably overdone and all this puts
unnecessary pressure on our creaking
system as it is I mean Esther you want
to have a heart for people yeah who are
genuine Asylum Seekers from all zones
and particularly War zones that we may
have been instigating Iraq and places
like this of course you do especially
women children from his War zones but
like I say when a third of all the
people coming in are from Albania that's
clearly that's not what this narrative
is about and they can apply for
temporary what do we do about separating
these various
types of people trying to get into the
country we want good migrants in other
words you know ones how you how would
you categorize without people are going
to work people don't even need if
they're going to work and start a new
life and contribute to Britain which
actually is most yes
a good migrant or or a proper Bonafide
Asylum Seeker genuinely coming from a
war-torn country what we don't want are
the others to come in illegally yeah
more like that and you know contribute
to sort of illegal um the economies in
in this country like sort of drug
dealing and all of that but I think that
the point is safe legal routes and
that's what we should tackle because and
that's why the left kind of lose the
debate because you have to have a way
for them well the government also loses
the way you have to have a way for them
to come safely and legally because then
you have a case to actually remove the
ones that don't have a case to be here
and I think that's what we're trying
everyone in the restaurant industry
tells me they are absolutely desperate
for more people to come back to come
into the country who are skilled but we
should choose those migrants as well you
know because I think migrants from the
Commonwealth for instance have a
stronger case and are actually more
beneficial to Britain than from parts of
the world that we don't necessarily
choose and I think that's something that
we should make a case for as well if we
take albanians out of the numbers for a
moment of the rest when their cases are
assessed the majority are found I have a
a legal claim to stay here as refugees
Asylum Seekers
no route for them into Britain except in
these boats now you you have a safe and
legal route you're not going to stop all
the savings because the people you the
people you reject or say one of the
problems five things that's the use of
language foreign
language often sounds unnecessarily
heartless and incendiary boasting about
shipping people out and all the rest of
it and I think yes it was today or
yesterday uh one of the Labor uh side
use the phrase concentration camps for
these unused unused holiday Parks right
where they're thinking of putting a lot
of the migrants as a sort of holding
place to use a phrase like concentration
camp I mean my mother was in the
concentration again
pretty offensive as a way of talking
about it and I and I'm but I you know
just to to uh to emphasize I also think
that Home Secretary has talked about it
in ways that are also quite offensive
yeah I think yeah I think that's just
that doesn't language matters but but
also it also it's also irrelevant as
well as but as well as it mattering it
doesn't solve the problem no it doesn't
um so it just like talks big and then
doesn't solve the necessary hostility
and I think she doesn't understand the
nuances and semantics of politics I
think you've got to be careful the
language I think well talking of being
careful with language you've done it
because you've been brought in today to
do what I never thought I'd be asking
you to do you're going to launch a stoic
defense of Kanye West probably right now
the world's leading anti-semite you as a
Jewish man are going to explain to me
why his music shouldn't be canceled
right after the break you've got time to
think about it that's the tease and also
still to become I'll be live with the
liver King I'll be speaking to him
exclusively if you don't know any one of
the most famous influences on the
internet he believes in Primal living
he eats liver like he just did but he's
also just confessed to take another
steroids and the question is how much of
that muscle is real from his diet how
much of it is from the steroids well
talk to him as well stay with us
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
what's the breaking news then it really
this is going to fill your heart with
Glee in the middle of a cost of living
crisis particularly given he was one of
the people who precipitated it with his
hapless management of the country Boris
Johnson has been revealed has made a
million pounds in speeches since he left
office in disgrace that's just a little
bit more than Matt Hancock has made from
eating kangaroo testicles after also
contributing to the downfall of this
country and it does it warms the cockles
of your heart doesn't it that these two
little grifters who had to resign in
disgrace are now raking in while most
people in the country are really
struggling I'm sure you'll all join me
in saluting this great moment for
British democracy thank you thank you to
everyone who's paying Boris to speak
because I would pay him to shut up
well the artist talking of shutting
people up yay uh of course the artist
formerly known as Kanye West is in the
middle of a dramatic months long down
the spiral centered around horrible
anti-Semitism it's cost him massive
deals with Adidas and GAP and he's been
virtually ostracized Now by mainstream
Society but should his music his art
also be expunged from Apple music
Spotify everywhere well still with me in
my my pack I've done you wrote a great
piece about this really made me think
because I don't think it's as
straightforward as your gut instinct
which is yeah banham you know it's a
sort of cancer culture mood we're in I
interview Kenya at length um about five
six weeks ago and that was when he just
had said about going Defcon 3 on Jewish
people and I wanted to find out what he
meant was it actually something we
didn't think about did he have a good
explanation he didn't really it looked
at me like blatant anti-Semitism based
around his belief that the music is
wrong by Jewish business people ripping
off black artists and it's all come from
that but since then he's become
increasingly in my view vile and blatant
with the anti-Semitism leading to him
being thrown off Twitter where Elon Musk
brought him back thrown off of putting a
swastika in a star of David as opposed
which was contemptible now he's gone
from Twitter too much even for Elon Musk
who wants to bring back free speech he's
gone from most of his corporate deals
should his music be part of the package
of the cancellation so I argue no uh
obviously I find his work what he says
repulsive and also frightening as a Jew
right so uh and I agreed with Elon Musk
I don't want to be in a conversation
with uh yeah so I don't want him to be
on Twitter but I do think artistic
expression is very important and he's an
important artist and to argue that every
person who has ever made a piece of art
let's take Wagner at one end or Michael
Jackson on another end everything that
they have done should be removed the art
should be removed because of something
that they've said about something else I
I don't think so um and it what I've
tried to do in that article is to say
these are matters of judgment that's why
we argue so much you see Kenya look yeah
yeah and he gets upset if you call him
candy but he wants to do another
interview with me he's been texting me
but I gotta say even in the text
messages he's been sending me he's
unbelievably offensive he's homophobic
he's anti-semitic some of it is
outrageous and that's just in text to me
so this is not something he's
accidentally blurting out in the middle
of interviews I don't want to interview
him again because I don't want to give
that guy a platform but I do think you
made a good point I mean as to where is
this line I
Christmas you'll hear Michael Jackson I
know I don't see people rushing up
saying get it off get it off I think you
have to separate the Artistry from the
person because it's at the end of the
day the Artistry is part of our culture
you know Kanye well yeah is one of the
most talented individuals of my
generation period and his music is a
form of is a part of you know black
American culture certainly but also
music culture around the world I don't
think you can but if you've been saying
all this stuff about black yeah we don't
have to like him but his music is a
different but if he'd been blatantly
racist about black people repeatedly
made his contempt for black people
obviously popular yeah but if you've
been if you've been a a white guy doing
it about black people a white artist
right would you say the same thing I
would because I think I I I'm very
strict with my standards I think the
Artistry and the culture around it is
different from the artists and how
detestable they are and I I think we
should we should actually preserve the
music I mean I still listen to artists
that I probably shouldn't say because I
will get canceled well Kevin When We
Were Young you know Gary Glitter oh yeah
the the party go to especially at
Christmas right yeah obviously go to his
Brixton show it was always a huge thing
and now you never hear him really and I
think he is on some platforms I think he
said he's on Spotify or something but
you won't hear him on the radio right
you won't play it and you won't see him
on television yeah
I think it's a principle that's just
that covers everybody so one of the
reasons there's a difference between
Gary Glitter and and Kanye West and I
don't mind that he's offended you know
he's offended me so
um I can offend him back it's because
Kanye West is just a more important
artist so one of the things I'm arguing
is common sense and a sense of
proportion comes into this and but if
you're an important artist should that
matter if you're it does for example
commercial I think the stuff he's saying
about Jewish people now is actively
going to lead to more attacks on Jewish
people I've seen it in LA where they've
seen you've seen banners over Bridges
people supporting him right and these
are anti-semitic people who might well
be violent that to me crosses every
possible line yeah so I'm not sure that
the importance of the art actually for
me is the criteria it should be what's
the offense it is interesting because
would you give them a venue would you
allow him to to play right you know in a
venue right so you might say no but then
you'll learn to be on Spotify but on the
question of interviewing him and I can
see your reluctance I also think there's
a value in exposing and Grilling and
holding it I've done that once and I'm
not sure there's any added value given
he's been saying even more atrocious
things what we're establishing here is
that each of these judgments is quite
subtle yeah so there's a difference
between uh him having a concert and
there might be a difference for example
Danny wait a minute subtlety and public
discourse
if you lost your mind there is no room
for subtlety in discourse swimmers all
take tribal positions and that's it so
Daniel you must be canceled Kanye must
be saved if he were to sing his tweets
we might feel differently about it what
about Chris Brown after he he brutally
well that's the thing it comes down to
yeah look it's all subtle isn't it you
made me think that column really made me
think and actually I came around to what
you were saying I think I agree I think
once you start it's a slippery slope
yeah if you expunge anyone who's got any
problems in their back catalog from the
artistic historical back catalog you
probably would you allow a few people
would you allow an overtly anti-semitic
song
I don't think those are so then so
therefore then on Spotify he could have
his back catalog but perhaps not his
future
well Kelly just released an album
as we can tell it's a fascinating debate
right yeah thank you very much Pat for
coming in I appreciate it coming next to
like another TV exclusive internet
Sensations living things speaks to me
live after the fitness influencer was
outed as a steroid abuser lying to his
millions of fans whose body it was
natural what's his justification what's
his defense we'll ask him after the
break
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well welcome back I'm a lover of red
meat but my next guest takes it to the
extreme Brian Johnson also known as the
liver king that's brought his
unconventional lifestyle to mainstream
with millions of fans but is his team
living all As It Seems
this is what the liver King is having
for dinner today I'm having liver with
breakfast lunch and dinner because liver
is King
[Music]
oh it can't be in here without your
shirt on don't have a shirt you know
what somebody said that earlier you
might not know this I'm actually wearing
a muscle shirt
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
I'm making this video to apologize
because I [ __ ] up
yes I've done steroids I am as sorry as
a man can be
LeBron Johnson aka the liver King joins
me now uh well thank you for joining me
uh Brian you're nine ancestral tenants
which is what's made you so rich and
famous uh our sleep eat move Shield
connect cold Sun fight Bond pretty
laudable lineup of tenants to have in
life I would argue
um but you've got to add another one now
10 which is steroid drug abuse how much
do you think that has damaged your
reputation and your integrity
first of all I deserve what you just
said and I also want to say thank you
for giving me this opportunity to come
on here to talk about this my job is to
acknowledge how bad people are hurting
today I believe there's this path
forward a better life to live I call it
ancestral living thank you for giving me
the opportunity to talk about this how
much does it uh damage my Integrity a
lot you know but but what I want to say
is this is um
my Integrity my my brand
um I would say that this doesn't have
anything to do with the north store the
North Star the message is far bigger
than me right the message really is
people are hurting at record rates
there's a better life to live it can be
achieved through an ancestral living
um it's interesting I got a text message
today from a very very famous television
personality who is known for his own
Healthy Living
um he said to me that you screwed up
with the steroid stuff but your heart is
good
you got you're a lovely family man your
views on living an empowered life
through struggle Primal nutrition Sun
ice and Community are spot on so
notwithstanding the steroid Scandal he
thought that actually the tenants that
you stand for that you've been promoting
still stand the test of time so I guess
it's going to be interesting isn't it to
see what your fans make of this because
a lot of it is down to trust isn't it
you come bursting onto the scene you're
hugely popular you're making all this
money but it's based on the belief that
your diet which is obviously very
unusual I've got some of it here the Raw
Liver that constantly eating that is
what turns you into the person we see on
our screen when in fact it's now turned
out to be largely driven by steroids
there's a trust issue there
I understand that and I hope that we
have the opportunity to eat some raw
liver together since since you have some
there
um
there's a trust issue here right and you
don't have to believe what I'm saying
but what you have to believe is that the
world is hurting at record rates that
these are the facts that 4 000 people a
day actually kill themselves that 80 000
people a day try to do it 85 percent of
the population they struggle with
self-esteem issues eighty percent of the
population struggles paycheck to
paycheck 70 percent are overweight half
are obese 50 are on prescription
medicine forty percent however will get
cancer and 20 want to have kids and
can't have kids so what you got to
believe is this these are the facts so
now how do we lead a better life how do
we get better how do we start to
overcome these issues what I believe
right and I've gone and visited with
modern day private culture tribes in the
Amazon and Africa and Mongolia This Is
How They Live these nine ancestral
tenants they don't have material
possessions they're kicking ass in life
you know so so what I'll tell you is
this I live this way before social media
I've eaten these things I have liver I
have some testicle right here I have
some bone marrow right here
um we ate this way my family I did this
before social we're going to continue to
do this on social after social we'll
continue to live this way I believe so
deeply in this that this is my why in
the world this is how much I get all
this and it's interesting to me look I
think a lot of what you say makes sense
and I'm sure it would benefit people the
problem people are going to have is how
much of you and your body has actually
come from this diet that you've been
promoting and this lifestyle and how
much of it has come from just taking
steroids because anyone can take
steroids and pump up so now there's a
sort of cloud over the like I said the
Integrity of your whole sales pitch
which is you can look like me if you do
this but actually all the time you were
taking steroids
sure
um listen I mean it's impossible to say
how much right but I'll tell you this um
there's a new video today on Tick Tock
before steroids were ever involved in my
life right if you want to know what's
achievable how I did it
um prior to any kind of enhancement
whatsoever go to tick tock check out the
video you'll see that
um while I think it's completely
impossible to say what percent right um
I would say I've achieved 90 of my
physical growth of my physical success
without any kind of PEDs whatsoever
but you also repeatedly in interviews
denied taking steroids so it wasn't just
a question of of cheating if you like
because that's clearly what steroids do
in this kind of scenario but it was also
a question of lying when you were
directly challenged about it and I just
that you obviously had you know I was
aware of you because of the sheer uh
huge presence you have online and my
sons knew about you and you know
everyone was sort of aware of what your
stick was but a lot of it was based
around a belief that what you were
saying was true and you know how do you
feel on a human level to have to sit
here now as somebody who's been proven
to be a drugs cheat and a liar these are
not things anybody wants to be uh
accused of being let alone admittedly
no yeah listen I feel like a total piece
of crap you know I mean I know what I
did was wrong I lied about it I feel
like I've LED an entire generation down
part of the reason why I feel so
horrific about it is I know what it
feels like to be 10 11 12 13 14 15 with
zero self-worth completely embarrassed
and humiliated of the brain and body
that I have right and so
um when I connect with these young
people I know how they feel right um I I
feel like I betrayed a whole generation
of people you know and so what I would
say is I hope you continue to engage
with my content right these nine
ancestral tenants these are the true
north this will enable you to live a
better life but if you don't engage with
this content what you still have to
acknowledge is the true north is people
are hurting and hating and suffering and
struggling okay and do you still believe
that eating raw liver is the is the real
answer to to life
you should have some too
I've got some here and I'm going to have
some
Piers Morgan eats liver with the liver
King you know well it doesn't not it
doesn't taste too bad I'm not squeamish
about food I'll pretty well eat anything
raw or cooked it tastes okay I couldn't
imagine living on it three times a day
but I could probably have a go final
question and we're running out of time
are you ever going to take steroids
again
so I'm currently on them right now and I
have a plan to come completely off of
them I believe so deeply in this message
the nine ancestral tenants I know that I
can come off of them I know I can still
kick ass in life okay you won't see the
same guy in a couple of months but I've
got to leave it there good to have you
on the program I appreciate the honesty
finally thank you for joining me that's
it for me tonight make sure you keep it
unsensitive good night
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]